everyone stop everything you're doing
because we are coming to Europe on tour
trash taste Europe tour 2023 is
happening we hinted it in a previous
episode but now it is official we are
selling tickets right now click the link
down in the description below Joey where
are we going I'm glad you asked let me
tell you right now August 30th Dublin
Ireland September the 2nd Copenhagen
Denmark September 4th Amsterdam
Netherlands which is already sold out so
thank you very much guys September the
5th Stockholm Sweden September 6th Oslo
Norway September 7th Berlin Germany
September 9th London UK and September
the 11th Cardiff Wales we are going to
all of those locations right now tickets
are available but they're going fast
click the links down in the description
below do it I'll see you there hello and
welcome to another special episode of
trash taste your Saturday Midnight Radio
oh yeah I'm your host for today gone and
uh joining me once again are the boys
one of those episodes where I just feel
like saying some outrageous [__] okay
okay
[Music]
I finally finally watched the Mario
movie oh thank you I thought you're
gonna say something outrageous I've done
that yeah
I watched it in IMAX 3D how was it it
was [__] awesome why why IMAX 3D
because the option was there at my local
Cinema and I was like well I don't even
remember the last time I watched an IMAX
movie let alone a 3D movie I didn't even
know they were still making 3D movies
yeah what do you mean because I was just
like ah [__] it no more no because like
3D movies were like kind of like a phase
yeah it was definitely a face everywhere
at one point in a fad and like 3D TVs
and [__] like that well every phase as
well I mean every every movie is
basically shot in 3D now yeah oh sorry
it is filmed and they're like oh you can
this thing popped shot at one point yeah
exactly I've watched two movies in 3D in
the cinema and both of them start with a
okay
I'm glad we understood that
I watched it too I liked it uh I really
enjoyed it saying this I just I watched
it and you know sometimes when you watch
a movie and you you pretty much agree
with what everyone already says you're
like like damn I'm not special yeah okay
so what was okay what was the General
consensus with that film because I
didn't get any reviews or anything do
people like it yeah people like it yeah
people like people said that Chris Pratt
was fine yeah a lot of the voice Jack
Black killed it yeah holy [__] he did
not need to go that hard as Bowser I'm
sorry you know some people were just
like you know I'm just getting my
paycheck and Jack Black's just like no I
was built for this role actually it
really was a kid
like everything but that's why it's so
good
do you think that was actually scripted
or did Jack like the shop in studio one
day and it's like I got a thing I got
I'd like to think that they cast him and
then halfway through it they're like hey
Jack
and he's like of course
that made me like irrationally happy I
was so happy when that happened yeah I
don't know why yeah it was just so fun
yeah the insane the insane thing is like
out of everyone I think he sounded the
least like himself normally like he's
done a lot of work yeah he put in a lot
of work
um oh I've got his uh name toad uh uh
Michael Key yeah he did not sound like
Michael King no no good good movie I I
almost forgot at one point that that was
Michael Key and I was like oh yeah it
was good why does he sound like that
though yeah I I will say Seth Rogen
definitely sounded like Seth Rollins
it was an interesting choice yeah I was
like yo Donkey Kong just hit the [__]
man
thank you
I definitely agree with the take of like
as a movie it's like fine like it's okay
but as like a piece of fan service it's
fantastic oh yeah because Nintendo have
just starved the world of anything
that's not video games for their like
characters yeah or everyone wants to
forget about the 90s live action film
you know yeah like you know the the
closest we got to like decent acting or
anything that was good with like the
porn Mario movie yeah because like I
will say I will say like I came into the
Mario movie with almost zero
expectations just because I didn't I
didn't really know what to expect from a
Mario movie do you know what I mean like
how do you make a plot out of out of
Mario like I had no idea where this
could go and I mean this has been
princess gets kid now Mario ghost it was
well it was very like a very Heroes
Journey basic story parents didn't agree
with what he does yeah yeah you've seen
it all before the story is not special
whatsoever it's very boring but if you
like Mario it's fun
it was just super surreal because I
can't see him I couldn't see a movie
like this existing 20 15 years ago 15 20
years ago because it just the entire
thing just felt like a meme I'm not
gonna lie this this feel like a product
of the internet and I can't put my
finger on why it felt like that but it
it feels like this movie was made for
like meme culture and just for kind of
like internet and maybe Zuma culture in
general I don't know I imagine like
probably people working on it probably
grew up with that kind of humor and yeah
the games and stuff definitely the part
where I was just like where the [__] did
that come from was the suicidal Luma do
you remember that character oh yeah yeah
I was like where the [__] cause like
there's no because Aki was like so is
there like a character like that in
Mario Galaxy I was like no well not like
that yeah I also realized that if you
don't like care about Mario that much
the movie's kind of ass
the size of Mario's scrotum thank you
for that I'd uh yeah I'm gonna continue
like I don't know it was fine I I was
happy yeah I was I was happy I I came in
I I came in not knowing what to expect
but just knowing I would get a bunch of
Mario references and maybe some inside
jokes and that was basically the entire
movie it was the highest budget new
grounds Flash animation I've ever seen
in my life because some of those scenes
where
um you know they just [__] I think
they start playing Beastie Boys or
something at one point and I'm just like
what is this
yeah the uh the AHA Take On Me segment
was a little bit weird
yeah as like a certified Nintendo kid I
think yeah it was really just like one
huge fan service to like the Nintendo
fan base but like I think they also did
in a really cool way because like there
was just so many [__] Easter eggs in
that film yeah especially like musical
Easter eggs like every time like a new
like Mario would get like a new power up
or like there'd be like a new stage or
whatever they would like do this really
cool thing with I don't know who did the
soundtrack but whoever it wasn't because
like they just so seamlessly
Incorporated little bits and pieces of
like musical Easter eggs into it like
when uh Mario got like the Tanuki suit
and for a split second you can hear the
Mario 3 theme and I'm like that's
[__] cool as like as like as like a
Mario fan yeah I noticed the Luigi
Mansions theme coming on when Luigi was
like by himself I was like oh like
Rainbow Road as well when it gets
rainbow run the Rainbow Road theme
starts playing I'm just like that's cool
I was like oh neurons activating oh okay
it almost didn't feel like uh like an
officially licensed thing it very much
felt like if you'd have told me like a
fan had made it yeah you're like yeah
because the whole uh like the one part I
did find kind of weird
um was just the whole Mario Kart segment
I was just kind of like all right
okay
but it kind of just felt like they just
uh were writing the movie as they went
along
like oh we need to put a donkey on here
okay let's uh let's go to uh Donkey Kong
Country okay uh America let's let's do
America uh Rainbow Road oh okay uh and
then they get eaten by a whale
for some reason you should have been the
most one out of ten movie and it
probably still would have popped off
yeah I mean it's fine so that's all
that's our like nine month late
discussion yeah so we all watched it we
all enjoyed it it was good yeah I also
watched I mean I guess we're on movies
um I watched guardians of galaxy three
oh I haven't seen that yet I heard it's
the first good phase Five movie or the
new like posts
yeah phase five of yeah whatever it is a
disease it feels like um that's fine
it's all right
and that's the review thank you very
much for joining in like I I I don't
know I don't know if like learning about
it because I I was not gonna watch it
initially because yeah I just because
like I watched one and two one was very
fun
two I I just found so boring yeah uh I
don't know if you watch I've seen the
first two yeah did you like two I
thought it had his moments but at the
same time yeah yeah at the same time I'm
like well one had the magic because he
had this new thing going on he had like
a [__] amazing soundtrack yeah and
two was just like all right we're gonna
do a little more of the same but not too
much different and I'm like okay well
it's good popcorn movie yeah yeah is
Guardians of the Galaxy the one with
Groot yes yes I mean it looks like he
looks like a [__] Roblox character in
this one and I just could not stop
laughing every time I saw him uh yeah it
was fine I mean like it was not the most
compelling movie ever the music was fun
it was great it was long right very long
the villain I thought was [__] stupid
um and he just he only just scream all
the time I don't know I can't believe we
were just talking about two Chris Pratt
movies yeah yeah yeah like I actually
found Chris Pratt pretty likable in this
one
um he's a likable guy in Guardians of
the Galaxy you know that's okay like
what's his name [__] dracthar
whatever where's the killing Guy the one
who shouts oh yeah he's still the
Baptista yeah he's still like the best
guy in that film oh yeah yeah every time
he's on screen I did get a chuckle he
was pretty good that he carried the film
for me um yeah it was fun it's a fine
yeah six seven out of ten maybe it's not
like it's like I don't know why people I
think everyone uh I haven't seen it so I
think everyone's just so starved or good
yeah I think she's people have just been
the Marvel fans have just been cucked
yeah like five years now that they're
just like oh something thanks James come
here for the next film right yeah right
right dreams come right we're making
another model film right
um so yeah that was that was nice yeah I
wonder if DC was pissed they were like
why why the [__] did you make a good
film when you're leaving them what the
[__] wrong with you own it in well
isn't he doing a new Flash movie as well
or something
yeah yeah see it where they're like this
because obviously if you don't know
anything about The Flash movie um Ezra
Miller plays The Flash and Miller Miller
is a very uh notorious uh actor and if
you follow any of the kind of a
douchebag yeah
it's an understatement just committed
crime he's like punched people in the
face yeah he's like a [__] up guy I
mean you can on screen now he can get
the list of some things he's a [__]
[__] and um well supposedly uh and uh
there's like articles being like this is
going to redeem Ezra Miller what the
[__] why are we why do we have to redeem
him why can't we just get someone else
who like isn't contentious and all the
critics are like this is this is the
best film ever and it's like I I why
like you could I don't know maybe it's a
piate maybe it's like a big brain Galaxy
brain PR move because no one's gonna
give a [__] about a Flash movie unless
you get some [__] to play yeah yeah
maybe I don't know it's I I feel like
okay I've been noticing a kind of I
don't know if it's like a trend or uh
just a thing that's happened recently in
Hollywood uh because I don't know if
they've they've obviously done this
before but I think
so much like AAA movies now like the
Mario movie like you know the new Flash
movie it plays off so much Nostalgia
hype because a lot of people getting
hype about this new uh this new Flash
movie because Michael Keaton returns as
Batman and everyone's like oh my God
it's the goat is the OG Batman who
actually cares about that other than
like die hard fans I'm sure a lot of
people care about that because a lot of
people might keep Michael Keaton was
like their first Batman yeah like that's
like our age group that wouldn't that
wouldn't really appeal to us yeah right
like we're like [__] Christian Bale
fan boys yeah that's that's what Batman
we grew up with right yeah yeah yeah
um so uh actually for me it was George
Clooney
the greatest [__] Batman film with
Arnold Schwarzenegger yeah because I'm
just wondering yeah that's him yeah
because like let's be honest we enjoyed
the Mario movie right but if like you
just said if we had no yeah if I if we
had no Nostalgia about Mario it would
have been a [__] move yeah no nobody
would have given
same thing with like the Sonic movie as
well you know I've watched the Sonic
movie and the only reason I enjoyed the
Sonic movies was because I am familiar
with the Sonic franchise not because I
actually think that they are good movies
when I went to the theater to watch
Sonic there was actually kids there when
I went to watch the Mario one there was
no kids there yeah
they're all adults says a lot about
Society yeah
I I think actually the Sonic movie was a
better movie for kids
um uh Mario movie if if you didn't play
enough Mario I just feel like you
wouldn't get off the movie I mean kids
there's so much [__] it's so vibrant
and light that I'm sure if 10 year old
me would eat that [__] up even if I
didn't know what Mario was but I mean I
don't know I think though with the Sonic
stuff like it's because like I think
Sonic has done a better job of I guess
franchising themselves more to a younger
audience because like they have like the
sonic boom animation right like the TV
show that they have you ever watched
that I have some I've seen like a
compilation of like Knuckles saying
[__] up [__] yeah sure it's so funny
it's like how is this a kid's show the
writers go hard on this yeah yeah but I
think because they've like you know
capitalized on that whereas Mario hasn't
really done anything like that
um yeah I think that's where it's like
oh there's a [__] Sonic movie well
I've seen it on as cartoons on you know
Sunday morning TV so I'll take my kids
to go watch it kind of thing of course
with Mario it's like well I [__]
played this game 30 years ago and uh I
want to see what it looks like today
yeah exactly how long do you think it
it's going to take before they make a
Pokemon movie that's not like detective
Pikachu like a straight up this is a
Pokemon movie like because I'm I'm
calling it now like uh because the Mario
movie did really [__] one box
officers there must be someone in
Nintendo that's having this conversation
right now if not like two years ago if
they just made black and white into a
movie it'd be such a good movie yeah but
they would never because that's like the
most mature Pokemon plot we ever had and
it's about like is enslaving Pokemon
okay and should we do it it's not gonna
be that it's gonna what if they just
remade the first movie but like with the
[__] budget of today's stuff
yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean like you know
Pokemon already has animated movies
anyway so it wouldn't be too much of a
stretch to change that into live action
so it would it would take actually less
effort than doing the [__] masks
Chris Pratt to voice Ash right no Chris
no not even Rogan not rock not even
voice Ash just play him live action you
know Chris the Chris Pratt has a 14 year
old Ash or however old Ash is now well
he would get cashed in there
but he would
that's just like 10
. no we should just know it would just
turn into a bunch of references it would
be like whoa pass me the jelly filled
donut whoa don't go there don't go to
Lavender Town play the poker flute whoa
like she's in our way whoa like I I want
to die so let's not let's not do that
yeah yeah but that'll work for the Mario
movies and I'll watch it if they bring
it in Pokemon like you I hate that I
like it
I hate that it works on me I'm a [__]
idiot suck though well I can't watch
Oppenheimer in Japan yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah I mean Connor having dinner and I
was like oh I'm so excited for
Oppenheimer to come out and he's like I
don't think he's getting released in
Japan I was like why isn't it getting
released in Japan
why do you think
you think the story about Oppenheimer is
not being released
but Christopher Nolan no
freaking Japan Christopher Nolan it's uh
let's uh like realistically I I mean it
is a shame because it's not like it's
like glorifying it in any capacity no no
it's supposed to be like a tragedy right
well I mean it's
a horrific event yeah and I think
there's a way that you I'm still I'm
sure knowing Christopher Nolan he'll
have a take on it that is interesting
and yeah I don't know yeah I could I
could also understand you just being
like let's just not let's forget it I
get both sides it was Pearl Harbor ever
released in Japan
I mean I've watched I've watched movies
about World War II in Japanese theaters
like they clearly they play them from
both perspectives they're not I think I
think it might have been yeah
if Pearl Harbor was released in Japan
then I have I have hope for Oppenheimer
I mean it makes more sense to release
Pearl Harbor in Japan than Oppenheimer
right like I mean uh yeah I mean because
the Japanese will be like yeah I think
I think it's a very different
perspective
I don't know if you've seen Paul yeah
I think it's a very different
perspective sort of scoreboard
you're the only one you're the only one
of this table who can say that it's like
a sports game guys
oh my God we got the advantages well you
know they they what's that I watched
another movie recently that came out
that was like of the perspective of one
of the pilots and who it was like a
goated pilot who would just killed I
guess Japanese people and stuff I said I
watched that in the cinemas yeah yeah
it's weird oh they get released go on
cow you're gonna oh no it was released
the thing is is that I mean nuclear
staff in Japan is still a contentious
topic to this day yeah especially you
know after 2011 as well even more so uh
you know so I I mean I can understand it
and also I imagine it's more of a
decision on the American side as opposed
to the Japanese side the American side
might be like yeah let's let's not yeah
I mean uh yeah from from the good thing
that I did it hasn't been confirmed that
it's like not getting released there
just hasn't been a release date yet so
it's weird though yeah like John Wick we
knew we were getting [__] it was
coming out in September yeah I mean it
was weird that the Mario movie was
released here weeks after everyone else
I'm like yeah how does that make sense
like this is a Japanese IP and we're
getting it after everyone else that just
goes to show how slow people work in
Japan it's like we are in the IP and we
still got a letter couldn't even get the
Mario movie God I do want to know what
the inner workings behind that is
because I watched it just with subtitles
I'm like why did this take a month I'm
feeling like like this could have been
done on Fiverr and
yeah because like I I watched it with
subtitles as well and I was you know
every now and then I was kind of like
reading the Japanese subtitles because a
lot of the jokes are very American yeah
yeah like very pun related like yeah
like idiom related and so I was I was
watching some of the subtitles for it as
they were telling some of these like
jokes and I'm just like I don't think
Japanese people are gonna find this
funny yeah like legitimately like I was
reading the subtitles I'm like where's
the joke
because it's like really hard to you
know [__] be like oh you know [__]
Mario's mushroom is like really big
it's like [__] dick and balls jokes
you know when like I remember like one
of the lines like Bowser was like you
know love really makes me come out of my
shell and I'm just like all right first
of all shut the [__] up and second of
all I was reading that in the subtitles
I'm like they just like complain
how much did uh the audience laugh in
your viewing of the Mario movie uh there
was only there was only another couple
an hour uh it was only me like giggling
away at like Jack Black yeah pretty much
I was watching the Mario movie and like
for 90 of it everyone was [__] like
dead silence right no that's Japan
that's Japan yeah and then like like
it's it's like every time that I thought
there was clearly like a joke there like
the one thing that uh like you know
stands out to me the most is you know as
someone like you know kind of like edits
jokes in my own videos there's a certain
like pacing and a rhythm when a joke's
being told like when when you have
really epic music and then you cut to
silence like when with with the scene of
like the penguin starring [__] like
everyone was like dead silent and then
they were just like randomly laugh at
like real like like when there was like
zero joke there like like when Mario was
just like running uh doing like the
Montage and people just started laughing
I was like what where's the joke this is
the hero's moment yeah what was from the
Japanese theater experience yeah I go
like every week and I swear to God I I
you you just if you just have like a
random number generator at any point
odds are like that's the only time
they'll laugh like you just stop it and
they're like all right it's frame where
nothing's happening and they're like
I watched um I watched uh the movie Air
it's about the like how Air Jordans was
made oh okay I was just like [__] I'm
just gonna watch it and see how it is
yeah so what yeah one thing I found
funny is that you know you know uh
Christopher uh uh Chris Tucker right
from like rush hour yeah he was doing
you know his Chris tucker-esque acting
oh he's like super fast talking yeah
slang and I was like I was like trying
to read the subtitles and I was like
there's no way they can translate what
he's saying like like in a way that is
like cohesive in Japanese yeah because
he's just like making a bunch of really
like you know Chris tuckerisms yeah and
I was like damn this is gonna be so
weird for a Japanese person to see this
translated it must just be like like
translating like sterile English or
something
um that was good that was fine movie
pretty good though they never shared
Michael Jordan once but they had like it
was very weird it's too expensive well
yeah they uh it was a weird meeting I
don't know if anyone else would watch
the movie I was just like why don't they
just show Michael Michael Jordan yeah I
mean I mean I I like going to flip that
around I sometimes get that feeling when
I'm watching like an anime and I'm like
I feel like I'm getting half of the
experience here because uh they sound
like uh they you know for something
let's say like monogatry or like other
anime where it's just like I feel like
there is more to this dialogue than I
can comprehend in the subtitles right
now but there is no possible way I can
actually like take it in fully take it
in without just you know becoming better
in Japanese
yeah that's why like at least with like
monogatari I've always said it was a
[__] miracle that there's even a fan
base for it outside of Japan because
it's like it's already such a niche fan
base in Japan let alone trying to
translate that type of writing into
English that still holds on to its
meaning and makes it just as good yeah
it's like I I always wonder I'm like who
who are these fans of monogatari that
like watched these episodes and was like
yes I gleamed enough meaning out of this
for me to like it oh well uh I I think
that just comes down to the writing was
just so good that even if you didn't
glean everything you still got like a
good enough idea to be like oh this is
this is still good yeah and maybe just
like a [__] ton of translators notes
back in the day if we remember that
stuff I think I think the biggest
hardest part was for me sometimes when
there are sometimes where there's so
much dialogue that's speaking so fast
and I'm like I I am breaking the limit
trying to keep up with these subtitles
first episode of Tommy gallon oh my God
that's just like machine gun on like
like it goes like like that was wrong
oh yeah that [__] thing
so like I don't know how easy it is to
like read like translate from English to
Japanese and be able to like read the
subtitles as fast because some some
actors have certain mannerisms uh and uh
way of speaking that I'm like I don't
think this slang exists in Japanese man
and you'll go you're always going to get
something Lost in Translation as well
yeah definitely yeah but uh what else
you guys been up to man uh you just came
back from a little vacation Italy right
I went to Italy it was fun yeah uh why
why did you you just wanted to go to
Italy or well yeah because I you know
the rest of our year is gonna be pretty
rammed uh and I was gonna go pretty hard
with work anyway and I thought you know
what [__] it I'll take a little time off
I'll spend a week I'll go to Italy and
I'll just chill out literally do nothing
like do no work which is crazy
imagine you doing no work how dare you
yeah so I just went to Italy I run to
the car and then drove around and ate
food all day dude I sound six coffee
game is unimaginable wait Which part of
Italy where he's North or South uh North
North okay I drove around the north
um I just basically went to I was like I
like this food where doesn't originate
from in Italy and that's why I went
there so like I love like Genovese
Genovese sauce yeah yeah yeah I love
that so I was like oh my go to Genova
because that's where it's from and I had
like just an ungodly amount of pesto it
was so [__] good dude it was oh my
God it's unreal uh I went to Bologna
bologna bologna bologna because that's
where bolognese sauce yeah from which
you know I wasn't a big fan of bolognese
sauce but they do it and it was UN
unreal how hard you got a dude it's dude
like I I you know I've been to Italy
before so I knew the pasta was good but
I just don't remember it being that good
it was like what do you mean I think I
was like I was like 16 17 18. I didn't
appreciate it yeah after eating pasta a
lot in Japan I'm like you know and I
thought it was pretty good here yeah I
thought it was all right and then go to
Italy I'm like
it's not even the same league it's like
it's like The Kindergartners versus the
pros it's not even like that I don't
know how it's just flower like how is
this so different like this is crazy but
like every you know and that pastors
I've just never even heard of yeah what
the [__] is this they're like actually
yeah it's a shack inverted of pasture
and we stop it when I'm like what okay
yeah give me that
um and and like like I said like the
coffee
is unreal how much coffee did you have
oh like you have like eight espressos a
day just because like heat ex oh my gosh
just because like dude you go anywhere
and people offer you espressos it's so
bizarre right so like Connor's like why
is my resting heartbeat for sure I I had
the lowest heart rate in Italy like yeah
so I you know I was driving and like the
first areas I drove around like I knew
the car but then after that it was kind
of annoying to have a car so I I ran
yeah I just got the trains because it
was pretty good
uh super annoying you couldn't really
like go around you had to go back into
like Milan and then go back right so I
was just like [__] this
um so I drove the first pop
you know where I went to actually
and I guess this all started because of
you is that you remember you bought us
the barolo wine yeah I went to barolo oh
yeah oh [__] so I I went to bed yeah
dude it was awesome yeah so Brawler's
such a cooler I'm something like [__]
son of the guy it's basically just like
this really like picturesque sprawling
Hills really beautiful I rented a Vesper
as well
now we're talking now we're talking that
was super high yeah like dude Italian's
just also like okay there's so much to
talk about Italians just don't give a
[__] full stop ever uh I go to rental
dude just didn't ask me for anything he
was just like come back in like a few
hours and then I was like you need to
see my driving license he was like oh
yeah yeah yeah and I was like oh thanks
oh yeah I do and he was like oh just
give me 50 euros then come back later
I'm like all right okay everyone was
just super chill about everything
um but yeah I know like so
as I was saying coffee everywhere like I
got on this train and I I booked like I
don't know like a the nicer version of
the the train carriage or whatever right
and I sit down at this train I get on
this guy comes up to me he's like hey do
you want an espresso
like the guy who works out I was like oh
oh yeah sure okay I'll take him to
scratcher Connor can never say no to
Expresso that was my I was like super
size me but for espressos it was like my
rules I wasn't allowed to say no to any
espressos yeah if someone offers me a
coffee good on the train though super
good because really dude this is the
thing that I learned about Italy it
doesn't matter how dog [__] the area or
the building or whatever your place is
in it could be like the most run down
like everything had an espresso machine
in it and a good one like I'm convinced
people who are like like can't afford
their rent or whatever they're like damn
I'm homeless but I'm not an animal holds
holds espresso machine you know what I
mean like it's like I went so then I
went on the train as well
and I went to like the the food
compartment where you can get food it
was Barren there was nothing it was like
two bags of crisps but of course there
was just a giant one of those really
massive espresso yeah they're like the
and they're everywhere and I'm like oh
I'm like can I get a cappuccino and he's
like of course it makes me cappuccino
every cappuccino is like one Euro as
well I was like this is [__] up this
is so cheap everywhere it makes coffee
amazing like everywhere everywhere does
the Italian government just give each
new resident of Italy just like an
espresso yeah it's like subsidized yeah
it comes with every house like welcome
to the country here's your espresso
there's gonna be something I'm missing
because like those machines are
expensive but they're everywhere
everyone has one
um and it's so good because some of the
taxpayer money is going yeah like I
landed I landed in the in the I got the
airport and I stayed at the airport
hotel like one nearby and I I stay in
this hotel and I wake up and I go to the
breakfast and I was kind of this I was
like I'm not gonna lie I was kind of
heartbroken because I went for the
breakfast yeah and it was like said
American coffee and just in this like
just Jog and I was like so I pour it and
I start drinking because I need coffee
yeah and then I see people getting
cappuccinos I'm like oh [__] they're
they're talking salvation I'm like what
they're like oh they're just to order
[__] I'm an idiot so then I had to I was
like oh I [__] poured this thing no
one of my coffees I've wasted it yeah I
ate a day
that was wasted
on an American coffee oh it's so good it
was just like the coffee the coffee game
in Italy is just the best I've ever had
in my life it's just the the the the
amount that everyone drinks and as well
as like everyone just cares there's no
like chains anywhere it's all just like
everyone just knows how to make good
coffee and there's good I didn't have to
go to a single Starbucks no actually
there is a Starbucks Roastery like one
of the reserved ones the righty ones in
Milan which I checked out because I was
like I wonder what Starbucks looks like
in Italy because it's gonna be like it's
gonna be good it has to be because
you're an idiot
I was like that's like saying McDonald's
has to be good in America right surely
surely yeah because I literally have
like an hour to kill and I was like yeah
it's right next to where I was staying I
was like oh [__] it I'm gonna have a
look and then I went to the uh because
they had like the they do alcohol drinks
in that Starbucks
yes right I suppose this is Europe yeah
yeah I had the like the espresso Martini
that they made with olive oil and [__]
it was [__] bomb it was so good oh
God damn dude but yeah I Pastor every
single day for lunch and dinner
um because wait did you get I don't know
I haven't checked
it's like dude you you I I remember this
as well but like Italians eat a lot well
at least
because you go to the the every dinner
they have the like first course which is
like normally like just pasta and then
you get a Mane but the pasta is like the
size of what I would consider to be a
main yeah so normally I mean just two
main dishes in a [__] starter every
night I'm like dying but it's so good
that I can't stop and every night I was
just in pain like oh I can't do it again
proceeds to do immediately do it again
yeah but it's so good
um and man Italy is just like I just
felt like when I was there I was like
man this is just Southeast Asia uh
there's [__] mopeds everywhere the
mopeds run heavily like they were just
[__] everywhere like Vespers yeah and
there was no parking for like bicycles
only parking for like Vespers and it was
just again everywhere there's so many of
them right you reminded me of when I was
in Thailand and then also everyone's
like loud very loud uh you go to like a
nice family restaurant and everyone is
it's like a different it's like
enthusiastic right I wouldn't say loud
as an like obnoxious more like
everyone's with their family they are
very very loud how's the driving over
there that's the real test yeah they're
insane they just they're not they don't
they don't give a [__] I'm pretty sure
the rules are a suggestion okay okay
because like I think they think they
have like an Autobahn but they I don't
know if they realize there is a speed
limit on it because I was going the
speed limit and I was the slowest person
on the road yeah
um
dude and like no one indicates ever okay
feeling at home I'm not feeling at home
all right
Asia but in Europe and it's hot you know
uh the only thing it's missing is like
super spicy food yeah but like it was
yeah it just reminded me so much of
Southeast hello Italians yeah no no no
no like I've always wanted to go to
Italy anyway I I kicked myself that I
never went to Italy when I actually
lived in [__] Europe uh but it's just
the [__] thing grass is greener on
the other side the only problem for you
is that you have to eat the crust
yeah I mean okay here's the thing Joey
here's the thing the crusts I can eat
the cross if the crust is good yeah okay
you know but 90 of the times if you are
in a [__] party and you order across
from like Pizza Hut or Domino's I'm like
nah nah this is this is not a good crust
all right but if it's like fresh Italian
pizza I don't like pizza once I should
pass it all the time I mean I mean I
would have a lot of pasta as well yeah
it's so good and it's so like varied
right like yeah I love pizza but yeah
pasta definitely has more variety for
sure yeah yeah there's way more types of
pasta I found as opposed to I mean like
pizza is very varied but you know it's
yeah it's some [__] Lighthouse I
heard I I remember as well when I went
to North Italy the seafood there was
also really fun yeah yeah I had a lot of
seafood uh whenever there's fish on the
menu I would just order it all the
seafood yeah it's really good grilled
fish was so good oh they're a big fish
too
um God you're getting me hungry man
you're getting me so hungry it's very
good yeah I think yeah I mean privileged
very very privileged to be able to go
there and enjoy it oh it's [__] bomb
uh yeah it was great I think there's
nothing I don't really have much to say
about it yeah when when was the last
time you went to Italy before like
going about this time
I think I skied over from France and
spent like a day skied over and you can
ski Oh Yeah from France to Italy okay
some of the things uh
um ski slopes yeah that was the last
time I went but I think the last time I
actually went to Italy was I think I
went skiing there and like right I think
touring or something when I was younger
but again I was like I was like 17 16. I
didn't you know I was just like
you know you when you're about that age
you're like I just want to play DS
[Music]
come on guys this episode is sponsored
by vessies if you've ever seen us wear
shoes in public our 100 chance it is a
vessies it's all we wear I do not leave
my house without my vessies I do not see
my wife without my vessies I did not see
anyone without my vessies all right I
don't even get married without my
vessey's true story I love the vessi so
much I wore them to my friend's wedding
also true story I wish we were we
actually just wear these everywhere
they're so good yeah I've worn these in
every single climate you can imagine and
these [__] held up rain sleet
snow or shine vesses will come through
with the clutch I never have to be
scared of British rain again because my
feet are always dry not only that
absolute maximum Comfort honestly some
of the comfiest shoes that we've ever
worn and look how stylish they are look
at these look at that man let them cook
are these bad boys are waterproof
they're super easy to clean as well and
they stretch all the way around to fit
your foot it's so comfortable so what
are you waiting for take advantage of
Bessie's Memorial Day sale and save up
to 30 on a variety of vessi styles
available at bessie.com trash taste in
case you missed the sale you can still
enjoy a 15 discount on your order by
using Code trash test at checkout don't
wait too long to grab your favorite pair
of bessies join the vessey club link is
in the description thank you very much
verses for sponsoring us today back to
the video to completely switch gears
from Italy uh I watched something
interesting reason uh it wasn't just the
Mario movie
I saw a Thai hentai
oh God what yes okay I think I know
which one it is okay because I watched
it too
where was my invite I I didn't know you
watched it either I mean it's got to be
right like it's yeah
okay okay okay
yeah to preface okay I feel like maybe
there's something in my blood for me to
be a [__] degenerate because I've
been to like you know uh Anime
conventions in Singapore and stuff like
that before and uh you go to the artist
alley and I remember going to uh AFA or
something uh and you know other
conventions before that yeah uh and
going to the artist alley and every
cultured artist like I would I would
hear them talk and everyone was Thai and
I was like ah My People my my people
drawing all these uh cultured fan arts
right so I had an ink link that there
were a lot of like talented cultured
artists and animators in Thailand and uh
this all came uh this all came to light
when I was just browsing the internet
and I saw what I thought was just like a
normal hentai yeah me too yeah I uh I
clicked the episode so the hentai is
called my mother all right
Hey listen I was uh it's like perfectly
as SEO generated yeah in Connor's knees
yeah it was called my mother and like
number two I noticed it was weird
because it was a hint I had never seen
before it was just released and
everything was like uncensored and I was
like what there's Sunset hentai now what
the [__] is going on so I clicked the
episodes and I'm like this isn't
Japanese wait oh hold on a second I know
what they're saying I know what this I
recognize this language this is this is
my mother's tongue
and honestly like genuinely the
animation was actually like pretty damn
it's very good really yeah yeah it was
like the character designs were so like
actually damn good the animation was
great but oh my God I could not my my
dick has never been more flaccid in my
life
[__] I'd never like I never have heard
Thai voice acting in the context of like
hentai
it was I I couldn't okay so the plot
okay with with a point it's [__]
awful as well yeah
um with a plot like my mother right it's
it's about it's about a guy and his mum
okay and uh hearing hearing a guy talk
to his mom and his mum talk to him with
the same phrases that I've heard like in
my household as well was just like ah
this is I was like oh oh my God yeah oh
oh yeah and they're blood related as
well which I was kind of like not on
board with yeah yeah that's nah that's
kind of weird now now you understand why
I'm not into MILF hentai
I don't want to think about my household
yeah I don't need it to be like the
[__] their [__] mom I just need to
be a hot lady who's older like I don't
need it I don't even have kids
like I don't need them to be the mom
they were like oh no this is the mom I'm
like no no it's weird yes it's a tie
which is not to be rude to tie but it
does not sound hot it does not I will
agree with you with that uh I think one
of the big things as well is that the
voice acting sounds exactly the same as
every Thai soap opera I've ever seen
alive but then you'd bring that to the
context of uh a guy and his mother
having sex and I'm just like Ugh okay uh
actually incest bad oh my God this is uh
I get it
get it now I cannot turn off this part
of my brain this is horrible I'm sure
people don't like it yeah
maybe bad yeah up I'm like uh yeah when
you hear Japanese do you do you have
like a separation between like okay this
is Anime versus this is stuff I used to
hear in my household because like I I
would hear like certain phrases in this
thing and I was I was just like hearing
hearing the mum say hey hey son come
over here hey son and I'm just like oh
don't don't say it like that don't don't
come on come on man come on I mean kinda
but like you know I think at this point
I've watched enough anime and handtime
in my life where I'm like this is
clearly this is completely two separate
things yeah and it's like you know none
of them sound like anyone I know so it's
like that definitely helps okay if it
was someone I knew voicing it then I'd
be like
no thank you turn that [__] off so Thai
people uh you are so close you're
pleased I gotta check please please
please hire a dubbing company I I I I I
beg of you I beg of you I don't I don't
want to understand that [__]
it's just called my mother
found it I think it was just on a hentai
website in general and it popped up and
I was like oh okay cool yeah I think
like I'm like oh I have seen this image
yeah because yeah I'm like there's no
way I haven't I haven't watched it but I
was like this is time that's Ty yeah it
looks good though yeah actually looks
good doesn't it why couldn't it just be
her with someone else like that all
right right preferable yeah because I
was really I was like there's no way a
hentai about Mouse release and I didn't
know about it already
I have the entire release schedule I
know everything that's coming out yeah I
do I I got like with the website I
normally watch hentai on it just tells
you when shit's coming out and I was
like yeah I'm only like in my head I'm
like I don't [__] like put it in my
calendar be like this [__] out prepare
dude
like a mental note oh my God sometimes
you know you you find out a hentai's
being released and you're like oh [__] I
like the first one yeah yeah
I can't remember how I discovered I
think it was actually Twitter actually
really sense yeah I don't know so I
don't know if it's just a me thing or my
timeline thing what's going on with
Thailand right now I saw that [__]
JoJo thing you retweeted as well uh yeah
I have no I have no idea I saw it
earlier before you retweeted I was like
oh that's sick yeah yeah and then you
retweeted us like this is legit and I'm
like
cap I mean I could I mean I could see
you Thailand doing it kind of get like
Thailand kind of just like as you saw
when you guys went to Thailand with the
[__] huge Captain America huge Mario
statue we just like taking like random
culture and just like inserting it
whenever we can even if it makes no
sense and being like look for the Mario
movie yeah like like the Mario movie
itself right yeah
um but yeah like it's it's so I could
definitely see uh a politician just
basically using JoJo uh JoJo kind of
like art to uh I mean he's got my vote
that's for sure
I mean I would say I would love for
politics to do more of this stuff uh
outside of outside of Thailand I would
uh probably make people more interested
in there or Japan like sometimes they
cosplayer right the people who are going
for yeah sure yeah well one it was uh
one of the weirdest things is watching a
manga artist I [__] grew up with uh
running foreign
boy that's why he's a goat yeah I
remember like seeing my Twitter where he
was he just had like uh when he was
running he had like an office or
something in Akihabara and I was like
this is this is so surreal right now
this is my like I I I read this man's
manga uh he was the Harem gods and now
he's just running for office like where
are we gonna go next you know but I
suppose I suppose that's not the
weirdest thing that's happened in the
world now that I think about it yeah
that's not weird at all yeah yeah yeah
someone being a little quirky isn't it
it was bound to happen in Japan
eventually yeah for sure yeah like stuff
that we say is we like is was weird like
10 years ago is like totally sane now
which is like the bars Twitter really
changed the bar for what weird is and oh
my God Twitter lately as well I'm just
like oh my God this is worse than
PornHub and Lively on one website this
is crazy yeah yeah it's it's it's uh I
have no idea what the [__] is going on
with you right now
um and I just like it's it's so weird
going on my feed and I forget to change
it for the for you because I hate that
it defaults to like the recommended feed
because that is just a [__] cesspools
it's like how have you said YouTube when
you open the app it just loads a short
sometimes you open YouTube it just plays
a short is it because it might be
because the last thing right uh so this
time I didn't do it but like let's say I
was just watching something I've noticed
that sometimes if I just close it and
then I come back to it later on it'll
it'll just [__] start playing a short
even though I wasn't watching ashore
what yeah I don't know
um maybe you just uh maybe I'm crazy
yeah sometimes it's like it's completely
reloading the app like I see it opening
it again like like from scratch and it
just loads of short I'm like what the
[__] [__] you how much shorts have you
been watching oh you know you go down
the rabbit hole yeah have you noticed
the amount of like on Twitter the amount
of like every time you open it there's
just one person just being dunked on
with 100
000 retweet or query tweets or something
yeah I thought it was cute originally
and then I'm like oh this is like every
single day twice a day yeah it feels
like uh like I don't know how to I don't
know if this is correct word like not
like bullying culture but like that kind
of dunking on people is coming back in
again yeah yeah online I feel like it's
slowly coming back in again yeah being a
hater it's cool I mean being hater has
always been cool you like even even
before the internet I just I just feel
like maybe Twitter has made it so that
it's come right back to the front line
again and I feel like okay here's his
I don't I don't know if Twitter still
does this but it definitely did it when
uh uh when it updated for like you know
changing from the just the follower feed
to the for you page uh so this is like
the smallest like [__] designs I've
like come across right so I wanted I
want my Twitter feed to be on my
follower feed because the for you page
is just [__] awful but when I when I
log on when I first when this was always
like the updates huh I always puts it on
for you no no so so originally it
defaulted to the follower but I would
get notifications I've got a little
little red dot saying you have new
notifications on your home page but I
couldn't get rid of that notification by
going to the for you page and uh
refreshing and going to the top of the
page so it basically forced me it forced
me with my little little [__] with
just just a little red dot care about
those little red dots
wait you you don't you can go about your
life without going like getting rid of
every little notification
is what do you mean look at all the dots
I have I have so many oh no no no no no
no no no I've got on iPhone is different
but I have six thousand and eighty three
hundred emails
oh guys 338 on Discord
pissed off about the things that it
thinks I like are Urgent like why does
my Fitbit send me notifications to tell
me I'm fat
he's [__] spamming [__] like wow
you've ran two days this week it's like
[__] off like I you know and like you
know BBC right I have the BBC app yeah
I'm like that's great that's hype I like
checking out news yeah what it defines
is urgent and sending me a [__]
notification before pisses me off yeah
it'll be like dog of the year actually
that's a good that's a good one yeah
that is urgent it's like it's like I
don't know it's so dumb it will be like
I don't know man needs 15 burgers and
hot dog eating contest
turn that [__] off I think you can
somehow but it's like why why do you
default do this like I hate this yeah I
mean I cannot get on with my day unless
like every little notification is gone
otherwise oh dude I mean there is there
is just something there and I it's a
really bad like this much always oh my
God like this much oh yeah it's a it's a
really bad habits as well because okay
so one of the I was actually late to the
recording today because we were meant to
meet up at like 10 a.m and I came at
like 11 p.m uh so
one of the reasons that happens
sometimes is because it's because of my
let's say uh OCD where I need to get rid
of every notification uh sometimes I
just like if I get a message sometimes I
don't even read the message sometimes I
just open it so I can get rid of them
notification you are actually the worst
and then I'm just like okay I'm going to
sleep so so you sent the message at like
9pm or something yeah uh and I was like
tired after streaming because I finished
like half past midnight so I was going
straight to bed I was like I saw online
I had notifications I just remember I
think I remember like just tapping the
notification and then I'm like all right
down to bed and then I woke up
this is why it's actually like quadruple
this explains so much about why you're
so as replying to anything it's just
getting a hold of you there's so many
moments where I've like privately
messaged gone about something being like
hey uh I need information on this and it
says [__] red yeah then I'm like
so you're gonna answer it all I think
people will get the assumption that like
gaunt is the most uh uh like what's the
word uh punctual or yeah get a reply
he's the worst out of all of us no he's
absolutely because I I you know I have
all those notifications but those are
the ones that I deem as like in my head
I'm like I don't need to answer these
right now right yeah because if like if
you if I get a text I'll check my watch
that vibrates and like pops up and I'm
like that's not important I'm gonna keep
doing what I'm doing yeah but if it's
important I mean like okay I gotta reply
to this all right um yeah so then I'll
reply at the end of the day of in a week
oh I I just replied everything on the
spot I'm just like I can't do that yeah
because then like what if it's not
urgent and like because it sounds like
such an ass thing it's like what if
someone sometimes like the more you
reply the more Applause you get right
yeah and sometimes I'm like I don't want
more replies because I want to do the
thing that I was doing yeah and so if I
if I reply they'll reply right away and
then I gotta reply again I'm stuck in
this cycle of endlessly trying to like
reply non-stop I don't know maybe maybe
I'm just blessed because the people who
like I reply immediately back to other
people like gone who don't get back to
me for half a day so I'm like all right
good my side of the job is done I'll
just wait till he comes back to me 12
hours later and I just keep doing what
I'm doing yeah for me it's it's like
it's like half of that half I check it
I'm like okay let me just reply after I
finish typing the sentence and then I
finished typing the sentence and then uh
and then I just like okay I've
completely forgotten uh what I needed to
do uh so I just like uh and there's no
notification there so I'm just [__] uh
because here's is something if I if I I
knew if I don't see it it does doesn't
exist I need to reply right away oh I'm
going to forget and I know that so I
wish there was a function to be like
okay you've read it but can you keep the
notification there I don't know if there
is a function like that yeah emails do
that that's a lot that's why I can
manage my emails because emails I'm like
okay I open the email but I can still
have a notification that says has not
read some apps like you snooze like line
lets you snooze the notification oh okay
you should be like Ping me again about
this in two hours right right yeah
that's that's what I need in my life too
yeah I think you just hold down
notification okay one thing that I don't
know if you've guessed ever done this
um we've ever mentally replied but you
didn't actually reply I do that all the
time well like in your head you read the
message and then you compose the
response in your head and then you think
you've sent it but then you just haven't
oh no have you done this this is like
next level intrusive thoughts
and then you're like but then you mean
you guys distracted by something yeah
and then you're like oh [__] I forgot to
send that reply I never had the worst
thing is sometimes okay I I go like a
step further sometimes I literally type
the reply out and then I forget to send
it no I don't know
I get a message like two hours later
it's like so you can reply and I always
I always sound like I'm lying when I say
sorry I literally thought I'd reply to
you because you always sound like you're
just like you sound like BS yeah you
always sound like BS but it's genuinely
true I do it all the [__] time either
eat like I just type I type out the
response I'm just like uh maybe I need
to like edit this I don't know if this
is the exact response I want I look away
and I just forget to press send and then
if it was on Discord it would just be
gone it's typing for like three hours to
me it's like the mental equivalent of
looking for your phone when your phone's
in your hands you know you know you know
what I mean it's not going to see your
pocket you got your phone in your hand
it's like where where the [__] where's
my phone I've got to leave now I've got
to leave I'm I was just I stopped a
swimming race one time I was about to
start I was like wait I can't find my
goggles and they're just on my head yeah
I've done that so many times
sunglasses as well
yeah I'm like I'm wearing them
it's probably why I'm into Gadget games
so much because every day I get it's
just like it's just a notification Fest
and I like ah let me do my deities and
get rid of all these red dots man let's
clear it out I when I played Hong Kong I
was like how many [__] mechanics are
you gonna introduce to me stop yeah
every five seconds is like all right now
we have this mechanic I'm like what is
this
many people like you yeah you want to
log in every day and feel like they're
doing a lot of things but actually
you're just doing nothing yeah I
remember when I first started playing
genjin for the first time like uh when I
go back into it
um like the first hour of that gameplay
was just me clearing notifications uh
and then and then I was just like okay
[__] now I actually have to play the
game but that was actually pretty fun
actually that was I felt a lot of uh
yeah that was a neurons it's like
cleaning your room it is it is right oh
it's all done yeah except it takes a lot
less effort so I enjoy it way more
because uh cleaning clean my room
actually takes effort you're doing that
while you're sitting in your dirty
officer right
yeah I don't know it's uh yeah my
brain's just wired weird uh yeah you
should only play gacha games yeah okay
okay here's the thing here's the thing
though
um yeah okay have you checked your
screen time like how much how much time
do you spend on your phone uh how do I
check uh so you go to your settings
right
so you go so you go to your settings and
you go to uh yeah digital well-being
parental control no why is it called
that I hope that it's called that
because that makes me sound like I'm I'm
sick so this week I've had a daily
average of 7 hours 47 minutes
[Music]
it's
it's bought it's down eight percent you
can tell me how many times I've opened
my phone yeah 160 on Tuesday what was
what went wrong holy [__]
[Music]
all right hold on let's see
okay so my digital well-being is
actually pretty damn good because I saw
some YouTube videos about this where
people had like 15 hours 20 hours what
screen time and I don't know how that's
even possible that means every waking
moment they are looking at your foot uh
looking at their phones they showed me
how many times I picked up my phone uh
daily average 91. yeah so actually like
90 YouTube yeah so actually like my like
compared to a lot of people uh I I asked
Sydney hers and she was like eight hours
nine hours and I'm like four hours uh
four hours or three hours 40. uh that
was that was that was a bad day eight
hours
um but yeah normally I'm in the rounds
between like
between three hours on bad days eight
hours but it never goes beyond eight
hours so I actually try to minimize my
screen time as much as possible I'm not
that bad
I don't know man I just saw one that
said 10 hours yeah that was um yeah like
10 hours four minutes yeah that's
because I was uh I was on a plane all
right okay okay I'll just watch YouTube
but like apparently I spent 33 minutes
on ubereats yesterday which how does
that even like has I I think what must
have happened is like I have a I have a
mobile uh a wireless phone charger and a
lot of times I just like when I order
ubereats I just leave it open so I can
see where the like okay okay okay but
like I also uh I go in and out of phases
where I need like audio playing when I
sleep
yeah but I just turned off my screen for
that that doesn't count towards yours oh
it doesn't no no no no yeah yeah I tell
my screen for that too so maybe I'm
coping
um but yeah but like yesterday this
makes no sense because yesterday I was
streaming literally from like dusk till
dawn right
um
and apparently I was still on my phone
for six hours how does that make any
sense I was I was literally I was
literally streaming the entire thing how
about myself for six hours
YouTube mainly
while we're on YouTube while you were
streaming did you have did you have uh
your phone your YouTube on while you
were streaming actually when I take a
bath I always watch YouTube when I take
a bath okay all right normally when I'm
uh
I don't know if I wake up or if I'm
getting ready I just always like look at
I don't know [__] I'm [__] knitting
to our phones what's uh well what
percent Halloween I'm like a diamond
rank screen time user I actually don't
actually don't like I actually don't
think you're that high because uh well
screen time for for this device yeah the
other device
I don't count the computer wait wait
wait okay okay okay okay because because
it's work right because it's work you
know would it would an office worker
count the screen time for them on like
Excel no because I'm always in front of
a screen it's either my PC I'm either at
the gym and I'm running in front of that
[__] screen I'm I'm either taking a
bath yeah I'm pooping I'm always in
front of a screen but the thing is if
you're on your phone you're definitely
not working this is like the screen time
I spend on my phone is is the time when
I could I'm sometimes working
stuff
but I mean I think it used to be a lot
more I think I actually I'm glad because
I've got my like I guess social media
screen time down I'm not scrolling so
much on Twitter and Instagram yeah I
wish that the information is nice but I
wish there was like how can I look at
like how long I've what are the trends
that I've spent on certain apps like
have I spent more this month yeah on
like Twitter like why is that let's have
a look I know I know a lot of people
have those um those uh
extensions on Chrome that can like
block you from going on a website from
certain time periods
yeah I I I'll block Twitter because I
can't trust myself to not go on Twitter
while I'm working yeah which I've always
considered that but I'm like
did you get good just like just control
it just like mine never matter yeah like
I feel like I'm I don't know in my head
I'm like I want to be I don't know is it
weird that I'm like I want to be the one
who stops myself yeah no no no yeah you
want to be in control I wanna yeah I
want to be telling like I wanna if if I
if the only way I can get control is
that I have to like physically block
myself I feel like there's an issue yeah
okay so I I actually saw this like this
is like a [__] Tick Tock or [__]
YouTube shorts kind of like device like
oh devices you need in your life and it
was literally a lock for your phone oh
yeah right have you seen that it was
like a safe my friend where where you
put your phone in the safe and you lock
it and you can't open it like you set
the timer and you cannot open that lock
yeah until the timer runs out and I feel
like if I did that I would obsess more
about how I could get this phone [__]
open this lock open than I would
actually trying to like not look at my
phone you know that that would be a
bigger distraction than actually having
my phone there in my yeah in my opinion
yeah I mean I understand understand that
some people they need to block things
you know like if you're I think it's
like gambling or something you have to
like you can submit the like the paper
saying don't let me in yeah yeah because
I understand stuff like that and yeah
but for like me personally uh for me
like self-control it's very important
for me to feel like I am limiting myself
and there's not some external Factor
that's limiting me yeah otherwise I
don't really feel like I've I've solved
the issue if I do have yeah an addiction
to any whatever it is
um and I I I'd get so [__] pissed off
if my phone wasn't locked and safe I
would so I'd be like I I actually have
to reply to something like I this is
stupid yeah I would find a way to like
go around that I'd be like okay now I
need to log into all my messaging
messaging apps on my computers now all
right and it would just like I don't
know that that to me would feel bad for
me because it would feel like I'm not in
control so I would be pissed off and I
would be pissed off at myself for the
fact that I would need a device like
that
um but you know I understand everyone's
Minds everything is different right
everyone has ever way uh for me I just
like feeling like I am in control even
if sometimes I'm definitely not in
[__] control everyone's got addition
to something everyone's got that
something that that they're like damn
maybe do this more than I should or I'd
I eat too much food or whatever it is
everyone has that advice or something
they're addicted to and it's it's up to
you to
keep control of that yeah well it's
awesome
hey hey hey hey hey now now now now I I
am I'm a gamer okay I I like the gaming
side I like the gaming side of it guys
I'm I'm in it for I'm I'm in it for the
anime characters all right um yeah uh I
played an RPG the other day
[Music]
uh it was called like the the cruelest
video game whatever oh yeah oh yeah I
saw that one was it one minute of it and
I was like pause I want to play this I
want to watch the video because I I
wanna I wanna play this game yeah it's
called fear and hunger and it's just
[__] horrible grotesque game with
disgusting things happening in it
um and yeah it was it was definitely one
of the coolest video games I've ever
played did you beat it uh what makes it
so cool I haven't had time to watch
John's video yet sell it to me okay so
uh it's a Dungeon Crawler mixed uh RPG
uh mixed with resource management and
you're dropped into this world in like a
medieval setting it's extremely
extremely heavily inspired by berserk
yeah okay because the the plot is is
that you get to pick one of four classes
and your job and each character is a
different motivation for why they want
to find uh he's called legard but in
this for all intense purposes he's
Griffith yeah Griffith has gone into
this dungeon to seek more power and it's
your job to go and find him like one of
the character's job is to like he wants
revenge one of the characters to save
him one of the characters is just
because maybe he's like a vessel or
something and your job is to go into
this dungeon and save him uh before he
dies because there's a time limit and
when he's gonna he's gonna get killed
um the thing is uh is that this world
that you've entered is not your world
it's like it's like a different place in
in this world thing like Dark Continent
right right again the game is very
heavily inspired
there's so many anime references in this
in this game uh and again it's just one
big Omen to like berserk it's a plot and
so you enter this world and it's just
really like unsettling like there's no
music right away right you know there's
like really weird like you know when the
the shuffling sound an RPG Maker it's
just kind of weirdly unsettling like
think of like IB and Mad Father yeah
they're kind of like scrolling around
this this world and then you know you
immediately get into this game and then
you're walking and everything's kind of
like this blood everywhere this body's
hanging there's also dicks everywhere
um everything is a dick right it's
really grotesque uh and you go into this
world and then you get attacked by two
wolves right away and you'll you try to
fight these wolves odds are you'll die
right um thing is though uh is that
enemies can attack with their limbs uh
and so wait enemies so so normally in
RPG enemies right if there are two
wolves then that's two turns by the
enemy right yeah one wolf won a wolf too
right in fear and hunger wolf one has
four attacks no no it would have so
certain enemies have certain ones so the
legs are normally for movement and they
are two arms means oh for both walls
specifically they bite but other enemies
if they have two hands they have two
hits oh [__] okay and there's a
dismemberment system where you have to
dismember the enemy to then be able to
land a headshot to kill them
um but there's a there's that balance
between you can go for a headshot right
away but the the chance of hitting it
very low but if you cut their legs off
they lose balance and it's easy to land
a head shot but if the enemy has arms
they sell they can still hit you and so
you can either get rid of their arms
first and then they can tackle you which
is a very weak attack right and then go
for the legs then go for the head and
it's like this kind of like Balancing
Act where you kind of gotta decide
what's the best way to go for and these
enemies do a lot of damage and let's say
an enemy has uh like a meat cleaver well
uh you know because the walls will kill
you right away and so you you load the
game up again and you you managed to get
into the castle right away an ogre will
approach you right away
and we'll hunt you down and he catches
you right away
and his dick is just out on the floor
um it's gross uh but what you'll learn
right away is is that this ogre when he
hits you with this hacksaw he just
dismembers you and you've permanently
lost that arm for the rest of the run if
okay uh and if he hits your leg you lose
the leg uh and if you lose both legs you
have to crawl for the rest of the game
um so it's it's horrible and so let's
say you you're fighting this ogre right
you manage to cut his arm off he he then
at one point during this fight and this
introduces you to this mechanic he he
walks up to you and it's really like
creepy he goes a prompt will appear
heads or tails
right so then you flip the coin and if
you call it correctly you dodge the
attack if you if you call that
incorrectly you just basically die
um and in in the starting one you kind
of get dismembered and then you get
dropped in a dungeon filled with blood
and you have no legs and you're crawling
around and it's [__] and so you
basically restart the run because you
you can't do also it's permade death as
well so if you die and you have to go
back to the beginning of the game oh no
no there are saves but here's the here's
the [__] up thing about the saves is
that the Saves The Coin tosses and if
you if you if you want if you fail the
coin toss uh a really Opie enemy will
spawn to greet you and your save doesn't
count and you have to fight the enemy
and that enemy can one shot
and if you if your party member dies
they're dead you can't revive them
and you can collect party members but
they also can get infected and they get
dismembered uh and again it's a resource
management so you're hungry right and
you have uh like MP and MP is hard to
refill uh it's called mind and they go
insane if you don't have enough of it
hunger there's not enough resources in
the game as well so you have to manage
if you want a full party which is great
because you're more powerful but you
need more food uh and so that's a that's
problematic oh yeah also there is
absolutely no merit to fighting enemies
because you don't gain experience yeah
you don't they don't drop items so you
don't need to fight enemies but certain
times you'll just be you can't run away
yeah sometimes it's just quicker to kill
them
um and all of the items in the world are
randomly placed so it's just like a pool
so in some runs you could just not get
anything op in other runs you might get
super op items right away
um or my run uh the item to refill your
Mana uh is alcohol and opium
it's called it's called Mind Right your
sanity right so the only way to to
refill your sound is to drink alcohol or
smoke Opium get high or get drunk and I
kept getting opium but I needed a pipe
to smoke it I didn't get it right until
the end so I I was like struggling the
entire game just carrying around bags so
what do I do with this like you get like
kids and stuff and you have to make the
kids smoke the crack or the Opium to
like help them this this out this sounds
like a fever dream here it's like a jlpg
on Craft and then like you know it's
like it's really like you know in the
start it's more like they're like more
humanoids and the deeper you go into
this dungeon and find more about the
world yeah they all start to get a
little more like really surreal and like
creepy and very kind of like uh what's
the some of the enemies just are
absolutely [__] nightmares yeah like
more nightmare fuels
are very difficult and it's very
unforgiving and there's like 15 endings
uh all you can do a bunch of different
things I got two endings both were kind
of meh it's really hard to get the true
ending uh yeah maybe it's because I'm
not a gamer but this doesn't sound fun
okay so rewind to about 15 minutes ago
when you were like I'm a gamer
so like it's it's actually an amazing
game
um okay and the story is really
fascinating because it's about like uh
so you're trying to save this guy but
it's about like how uh this like one of
the characters is like his village was
attacked by like the main characters
like country and Army and there's
different gods involved and there's a
whole lot of stuff going on and you pick
up books throughout by the way the only
way to get law a lot of the time is from
a coin flip so sometimes you go to a
bookshelf and to get more law you have
to win the coin flip and if you don't
you just don't get the law
um but again like the entire game and
like a lot of reviews say this like the
difficulty does not come from uh like
any kind of gameplay it's all like no
the difficulty comes from just knowing
what to do because like as well in the
game right you you have a coin flip
right yeah you're like great this is
awesome I 50 50 chance for everything
that is not awesome that is the opposite
of course the game doesn't tell you at
any point uh unless you click on the
item which you would never do is that
you can pick up stuff called lucky coins
and they're very rare but when you do
get them you hold shift down the game
doesn't tell you any of this you hold
shift and then you flip two coins
and then now only one of them needs to
land honest so you've made it from 50 to
75 chance so now suddenly saving becomes
at least a little bit safer 75 oh no
so yeah and then like you know you're
also like walking around and there's
like prompts at the bottom of the screen
sometimes there's tell you information
like oh your party member's hungry is
yeah it's going low and sometimes
there's like a prompt and you have no
idea what this this prompt means and
initially it goes a terrifying presence
has entered the room uh and you're like
what what does that mean and throughout
the game there's just this like think of
like Pyramid Head yeah like Silent Hill
just following you and he's op as [__]
and he's just hunting you down so
there's also this added pressure of that
already on along with resource
management and just trying to survive it
just after watching John's video I was
like I think I would love this game but
it just sounds way too [__] stressful
for me right now it's stressful but I
think think it's a good kind of stress
where you feel very rewarded the moment
you find stuff out right like I in this
world as well like there's this item
that I wasted because I didn't know what
it was because it's not explained to you
nothing is explained to you in this game
yeah if I didn't have twitch chair I
think I just would not have played this
game because it's just like I don't
understand how you would learn anything
without looking up a guide yeah you
can't play this game without a guide I'm
pretty sure I just don't know how oh not
without like a ton of trial and errors
yeah you have to do like but even for
this example right how would you learn
this and like maybe it's hidden in one
of the books that you've just coin flip
for you've got a thing called an empty
scroll and I opened it up and I couldn't
close it I didn't know what it was and
you just type stuff in and I was like
well I can't do anything and you you'd
put three verses in I was like what the
[__] so I wasted it and then right at
the end I picked up another one and
someone in my chat told me oh by the way
you can just ask God for anything
I was like what
it's like yeah you should ask for
anything yeah I'm like are you kidding
me and I'm like how what's God
so in the game the the theme of God
plays a very like uh becoming God or uh
the existing Gods play a very very heavy
role in this and you start to learn more
about the gods okay and so you you can
just ask the God for something but you
have to type in like a very specific set
of words initially before you can ask
for what you want and I'm just thinking
who the [__] would find this out but
then you know I I did it and I I someone
in chat told me asked for this thing and
asked for it and by the way to there's
there's healing items in the game and
your characters have 100 HP and you only
get healing items every now and then and
they've been here for like 10. so you
can barely ever heal your party to fall
yeah gate found me this thing where you
can just
I heal your whole party for 30 health or
40 Health with a spell that costs MP and
you can regenerate MP pretty easily so I
was like what the [__] this makes the
game so much easier because if I didn't
get this stupid [__] spell I wouldn't
have known that yeah so it's like you
you it's very punishing but also it's
really cool kind of uh trial and error
experimenting I'd say like the best way
to play the game is to just grind a
little bit just die a bunch figure stuff
out it's very satisfying and then when
you get kind of later on just [__]
look at a guide It's so funny oh no that
from the way you describe the game
that's like a level Beyond okay this is
a hard game and if you like it's so hard
it's easy but you just need to know what
to do okay that's the thing color like
brain surgery isn't hard yeah it's easy
if I gave you a Rubik's cube right and
you were able to put it in online and
then have the algorithm walk you through
every movement yeah like I wouldn't
describe that as hard right like
following that algorithm whereas try
giving someone a Rubik's Cube for the
first time being like solve it that's
hard right yeah so it's the same
challenge but when you're presented with
more information the challenge becomes
exponentially easier so it's not a it's
not a difficulty that derives from any
skill or anything like that it's not
just it just sounds like you have to be
a Madman to play through the game enough
to get the information you need oh yeah
like the amount of trial and error you
go through right oh [__] yes I mean like
I think I I went through most of the
game without looking at anything and I
got I was able to get decently through
the game uh and it was pretty much just
when I wanted to start actually getting
the endings where I had to actually look
what to do because the endings are very
odd to get like I just went through
do killing everything that I could until
I got to an ending and it was just a
weird ending I I yeah from before it
sounds like this sounds like a streamer
game you know I I can't stream it there
like that's the thing is that like you
could only stream it recently because
someone had made an answer like a
censored mod right because it's like
there's like there's gold there's sexual
assault in it uh really [__] up things
right uh John's video is sensitive to
[__] yeah okay it's hard to recommend
but it's like it captures that that
really uncomfortable horror vibe that I
haven't had from a game in a very long
time that I really enjoyed so I thought
I'd recommend everyone play it because
it's not everyone sorry [__] no do not
play it yeah kids uh if you found I
found the new gameplay really [__] up
games that challenge you and really make
you feel anxiety and scared then yeah
it's great I fully recommend apparently
there's a second one as well which is
even harder than the first one I've
heard well yeah I mean from what I I
haven't played it obviously but uh from
what I understand from the plot it's um
uh if you'd like it's very anime-esque
very takes a lot from uh Majora's Mask
because yeah okay there's a moon right
it's evil and there's three days and the
premise of the second game is that it's
a more open world and you have to you
have to be the there's like 20 or 10
other people who come on this train
journey that crashes and then you have
to kill everyone else and be the last
person alive right damn but you don't
have to kill people and stuff but it
sounds interesting and it's set during I
think World War II yeah I probably that
it probably wouldn't be a game for me
just because I have I don't I have
patience but that just sounds like a bad
time I liked it because I I loved
berserk a lot and it really love jumping
as well it's like yeah yeah yeah it kind
of captured that kind of really
uncomfortableness that berserk gave me I
mean because it's basically like a yeah
yeah there's direct comparisons to like
and you can you can
there's a you can [__] get guts's
armor in the game like you can go
there's a place where you can get this
armor that penetrates your body yeah
like spikes and stuff
um but like yeah that's it's cool
because it's kind of like what if
somebody who was very heavily inspired
by berserk kind of did a very [__] up
I mean it was pretty [__] up yeah yeah
like a different take on it for a video
game where you can really delve into it
and kind of have branching paths it's
really interesting I really enjoyed it I
thought it was cool yeah I mean I
probably I still need to play the new
Zelda that comes out before I get yeah
yeah that's that's what I've been doing
I'm not watching that four days are you
not touching that I think I'm gonna
chill out for a little bit I'm good
I know I know it's good I just is it as
good as people are making it out to be
is it better than breath of the wild
it's like I don't know it's obviously a
direct sequel
um like it literally takes place right
after the events of the first game yeah
uh but kind of also is like the law
behind it is also like kind of
pre-quilly as well so like the it's it's
the events that are happening in real
time after the first game but the story
is more so about before the first game
is the story better I think the story is
a lot better okay for sure I think I
think the story in the second game is a
lot better because you actually like get
to find out more about like Zelda and um
you know the kind of state of Hyrule at
the time and like Ganon in this game is
just so he's such a Chad he's he's so
hot I'm just saying it right now I'm
saying it right now this like because
this is full on voice acting now and oh
okay and Ganon and like all these
characters are like just full on talking
and the Japanese voice does link talk uh
no links
as he usually does but like uh when you
go to like certain areas in the game
where you can uh pinpoint pieces of
Zelda's past uh there's just full voice
acted cutscenes and ganon's voice
gannon's Japanese voice is [__] hot
I'm just gonna say it outright it's
[__] badass do you sound like joto I
imagine you sound like jotra he's like a
cross between Johto and Dio yeah well
it's it's [__] badass yeah but like
um the the power-ups are completely
different now that you get like so like
breath of the wild it's like a lot of it
had to do with like using bombs yeah
right and the Chica slate stuff uh this
time it's way more like I guess craft
based yeah it's like nuts and bolts it's
like Minecraft basically yeah I saw like
the vehicle building like system that
they had and that looks like a lot of
fun yeah using that in like all the
temples to like kind of basically craft
[__] to get over certain puzzles is so
[__] satisfying when you get it right
and just some of the [__] I've seen on
Twitter breath of the wild speedrunners
are gonna beat that game in 10 seconds
yeah like some of the [__] I've seen on
Twitter of people making these like
insane Contraptions and like I saw a
Japanese did on Twitter who just made
like a full-on Gundam holy [__] like he
made like a functioning Gundam that just
[__] walks and shoots lasers through
his hands and [__] just destroys about
Goblin so it's just like I feel like the
creative side of like breath of the wild
is just like Amplified tenfold in this
new game people have been really
creative about how to torch a [__]
Crocs oh whatever right yeah I've seen
so many Twitter Twitter memes and
Twitter threads being like this is uh
how we've committed war crimes against
chorus here a thread isn't it the same
map as breath of the wild it's pretty
much the same map but now there's like
an extra layer above it and an extra lay
below so now it's it's literally like
Minecraft where it's like the they have
like kind of this underground layer
which is an exact copy of the the
surface but it's like the nether in
Minecraft so you go down and like the
enemies are harder it's harder to heal
they're more resource and stuff like
that and then there's also islands in
the sky that you can fly up to and
there's like extra little layers there
so the world is like three times bigger
now
I just know it's gonna be addict I know
that's I've been playing it for the fast
like I think I've already sunk like 40
50 hours into that game yeah it sounds
like it's even bigger than a breath of
the wild which I already put enough
hours in yeah
um other puzzles any better because I
know like one of the big criticisms was
that oh you know the you know it's
missing the Zelda magic because the
puzzle's aren't as good as they were
before
um I think the puzzles in this one at
least for me personally are a little bit
more challenging because you do have to
kind of get more creative yeah with the
puzzle I mean some of the puzzles are
like just a walk in the park where it's
just like more of a tutorial on how to
use certain abilities and [__] but like
yeah some puzzles I was like
legitimately stuck on for like a long
time like others like others I literally
just had to like cheese it just be like
I'm pretty sure this is not the intended
way of doing it but I still got through
it I think they know that I think yeah I
know that you can cheese it and that's I
think that's part of the joy right I
think so yeah the game is fun it's like
all I'm pretty sure this isn't the way I
was supposed to do it but I still did it
yeah yeah that's pretty high I feel like
you're smarter than the game yeah
exactly yeah exactly like Zelda like
breath of the wild uh especially and you
know the new game as well it just seems
like a game built for speedrunners oh
yeah speedrunners are like frothing at
the mouth being like how can we break
this game in the most efficient way
possible I mean I think like the breath
of the wild 80 Speed Run is like 20
something minutes or something yeah it's
just like stupid to watch it's just like
I've never seen a game from like the
modern era be that [__] destroyed by
speedrunners wait ever it is it is
beautiful to watch yeah I just I I
really want to play I I do really want
to play it's just I also want a life as
well I don't know I know it's like one
or the other which is the big reason why
I still haven't played Elden ring it's
just like it's it's those games where
like I know once I start I I'm not
stopping until I finish it I mean that's
why I was like kind of dreading uh you
know stepping into honkai yeah because I
was like I already am obsessed with one
game itself I do not want to balance the
other game okay but like the thing and
the thing okay part of the reason I am
into games like honkai and uh you know
um Genji and stuff like that it's
because
are they are they better games than
other AAA games out there I would say
you know especially genshin no you know
it's genshin is not better than
something like breath of the wild but is
it more manageable to play through a
game like that for me at least for me
then AAA game that I'm going to spend
hours and hours in yes it is more
manageable I can load up honka on my
phone and I could play for a little bit
and uh that's no issue at all you know
when I get into a game like Zelda or
Elden ring I'm like there for eight
hours yeah that's not like the game I
feel like they always trick you like
game mobile games like that because like
you've it's like how
sometimes you think that like watching a
YouTube video is easier and more
convenient than watching Netflix or
something because you think that like oh
I can just pause at any time and stop
yeah and it's it's low low risks it's a
it's not a big thing it's like a AAA
movie right yeah but but I think you end
up pretty spending more time playing
like honkai or gentian or whatever in
like because you feel like it's so easy
to play it oh yeah yeah I mean just
because you feel at any time you can
stop and there's no pressure you know
what I mean yeah I feel like because
they allow you and almost encourage you
and it's advertised in a way and the
game feels low low stakes so you don't
feel like oh I'm gonna just I'm gonna
play a little bit and then you play for
like five hours then I mean I mean ring
is more like okay I'm committing to this
boss yeah yeah like like for me for me
that's that's the that's what makes
gacha games so I guess appealing to me
is that there is that choice there is
that choice between like okay sometimes
I just want to grind out the story of
Hong Kong and I play for like five hours
or something that's great and then
sometimes I just I can just load up my
phone do like a single side quest uh and
then that's that's completely fine as
well I'm always making some kind of
progress and depending on what my
schedule is like what my life is like at
the time it always fits the schedule
like no matter what and that's what
makes it just so much more accessible
and the fact that you can play it
[__] anywhere you can play it on PC I
sound like an ad read right now but that
genuinely that generally is why I play
them you know because it's just suited
towards uh towards my gaming stuff I
just need that experience though that
blows your mind and that's like album
ring as long as you need that
I don't know like okay life-changing
experience okay back back to the hashtag
ad but honkai has like genuinely
surprised me I I genuinely think it is a
good game with moments that I did not
expect from a gacha game like there were
moments later in the story which I'm not
gonna spoil but but like made me like
genuine like holy [__] this is not just
Gadget game good this is just like good
good now and it's it's it's like I it
worries me as well just because it's
making a [__] ton of money and while I
do like honkai
um I don't want every game in the gaming
industry to be to be like a gadget game
because at the moment right now honkai
feels more like a triple a game with
gatch elements right which I don't know
I mean I I think the the turn-based
combat when when that's happening I'm
like oh this is good and we go to the
Overworld I'm like oh
you know what I mean like it's I mean
it's a great game it was fun yeah yeah
it was just like oh it's just like super
limited and very like I don't know it
didn't feel bad I haven't played enough
to say any opinion but like from the
little I did play last night on stream
um yeah I I I've kind of I'm a little
bit on Corner side in that instance
where I like the the actual gameplay
like battle elements yeah I think that's
like really polished incredible oh yeah
yeah they've crushed it on the
turn-based combat yeah turn this combat
feel
kind of exciting yeah uh which I like
because normally I'm I don't like
turn-based comebacks I think it's boring
yeah um but they've done it in a way
that feels pretty active
um and yeah it's very flashy yeah I made
the joke on stream yesterday where I was
like oh finally I can play a tone-based
RPG and not have a dead stream yeah
it's on stream and it just does no you
can't play like a Final Fantasy on on
you know stream and it do well
consistently I mean yeah like I've just
played the RPG as well right that's
turn-based combat and that did life I
mean it sounds [__] weird to praise a
dismemberment system but that was a a
kind of gameplay that was kind of
exciting yeah yeah yeah there was that
tension there right yeah and it's Unique
if you get hit there was consequences
yes in a lot of term is combat and kind
of engaging too I don't really [__]
give a [__] if I die yeah there's no
consequences for dying or failing a
fight so I I rarely care yeah yeah I
yeah like I think I'm starting to get
sold on turn-based combat I there are
still some systems like it's it's so
join us I mean it's so weird right
because I really really like the honkai
turn-based combat system because but
that's just because it's there's
something about it that just feels so
satisfying and I don't know why it's
really satisfying maybe is the
flashiness maybe is my monkey brain go
oh pretty colors like
the alts are pretty [__] flashy yeah
yeah because the thing is it's not that
complicated compared to other turn-based
combat systems I've played in fact it's
a very very similar to the trails series
which I got into before you look at
Final Fantasy and you're like how many
[__] magic spells do I have and yeah
I gotta manage all the the Buffs and
debuff like the whole car is like two
yeah yeah and and I would say this you
know as someone who's like now finished
the first two games of like the trails
series I [__] hate the combat system
man it is it is uh it's turn based and
it's more complex than honkai but I just
find it boring man it is to me it's just
boring and I don't I don't know why
um maybe it is maybe I am just a basic
ass gamer who wants pretty colors and
nice music but that that to me yeah like
that's important music music is such a
big factor in whether I enjoy video
games especially if I'm doing something
as mindless as like turn-based combat
yeah that's why Persona is the ghost
yeah yeah that's why persona it's the
whole reason why I'm like the one thing
I'll say like honkai has
some great music
they did not have to go that hard
the boss theme they did not have to go
that hard that's pretty good yeah I do
you find that turn-based combat uh
almost benefits when it's simpler as
opposed to being very complicated
I think there's a fine balance whereas
like I've played like a variety of like
super simple turn base to like [__]
symbol like Pokemon yeah Pokemon is very
simple right it's you you choose between
four moves at most you know
um some item management and that's about
it and party management right yeah
whereas you play you know like some
early Final Fantasy games for example
where it's like all like you know some
of the Dragon Quest games where you just
have like every character has like 70
different spells 70 different items you
can choose from I think It suffers quite
a lot when it's over complicated because
you just like you look online you're
like here's the most broken combo that
you can do that one shots enemies yeah
because the devs didn't think about
combining [__] stupid spells yeah
like this yeah it's like because how
could you have yeah in the game's only
con Patrick yeah so yeah maybe there's
just when it's too complicated I always
find there's either you always over
you're either completely over optimized
and you're one-shotting everything yeah
later on in the game or you're
completely under optimized because you
do you're playing the game normally and
you're like I don't [__] know how
this all interacted yeah yeah like I
think that there is a like a balance
there's there's like a golden spot where
there is some complexity to it but
there's not too much that you kind of
get overloaded because uh like pretty
straightforward right yeah Persona is
you do physical attack you shoot a
weapon or you use spells that's yeah for
me like Persona has that perfect balance
some some more traditional jrpgs like
um like I'm gonna go back to Trails for
example which you know on top of its
combat system it has like the equipment
system as well and it's there are so
many different [__] ways you can
build a character which is like great to
some people but I'm just like uh I just
like because here's the thing for air
like in intros like it goes through like
stages so you have like you have like a
certain storyline then you go to the
next storyline the next storyline
um and I was like looking up guides and
apparently there's like Optimal builds
you can do for each character that suits
that like Mission the most and I'm like
and I'm like this is too much prep time
for me to play the game I just want to
play the game I want to get through the
story but sometimes I spend like [__]
hours just going to the shop being like
okay what are the new items available
now what are the new um courts available
now okay how do I how do I optimize
these for my party which is like already
out of like eight members in my party so
you need to choose four members from
your eight member party and then out of
those four members you have to decide
what equipment you want to give give
them how you want to build them and
that's just for one Mission I
extrapolate that for like eight missions
in in terms of the entire game I'm like
this is this is too much that was my
exact problem with the new Fire Emblem
game as well right where it's like uh
where I was like that was the one game
where I realized I was like oh maybe
having too many playable characters is
actually detrimental to the game because
the new fire alarm game you can
literally play like 40 different
characters yeah it's like and there's
like Guides Online of like all right so
uh with this character you can do this
optimal build and this character you can
do this optimal unless are going to be
doing this Mission with these characters
and I'm just like I just want all the
cute girls in my team a game okay just
make them all op and just [__] power
through it that's what I want to do it's
comic game with like four characters
that feel fun to play and all feel very
distinct and unique and have good like
personality and character writing is so
much more compelling than 50 flashy
characters that I can customize in a
million different ways I was like just
just just [__] give me something good
yeah don't throw a bunch of [__] at me
that looks pretty exactly and I'm like I
know some people really love that aspect
they love like getting the spreadsheet
out and trying to optimize the build I
I'm not that gamer I once like for me
I'm a story kind of gamer I just want to
get through the story and just you know
I want to feel a little bit rewarded for
doing some cool [__] in the gameplay but
I don't want to work that hard where I'm
where I'm literally like spending hours
upon hours trying to like read through
stats read yeah I remember in the Fire
Emblem one I was like all right I'm
gonna see like just what the incident
has to say about like which characters
might be best some [__] had
created a [__] tier list of like
literal tier list of the characters from
like s to F right and I was like all
right let's see where my choice of
characters are the majority of them were
like D or F and I'm just like well you
know what [__] this list I like these
characters I like so I'm gonna [__]
use them yeah I don't care like all the
top tier characters are like all the
boring characters and I'm like okay
what's more important me like having an
easy time and like optimizing my
gameplay to make it so that I just Crush
everything or make it a little bit more
challenging but just have the joy of
playing the characters I actually want
to play as yeah right yeah I'll always
take the latter in that instance yeah
and to me like a lot of that that's a
lot of reason why I don't like
turn-based combat is because not only
the time-based combat itself but the
prep that comes before the turn base
combat uh and I think the two games I've
played where I've liked the turn-based
combat is when they've hit that
Goldilocks zone where uh it's uh just
you have you can you can prep you can
think about your team com but it doesn't
take too much time and it's still
rewarding and the two ones are now
Persona and now Hong Kai because those
have like hit the Pokemon Pokemon I
tried getting Pokemon but it's just too
easy I don't know it's just too bad I
mean that's why people make artificial
difficulties yeah you make challenges
out of it and stuff because it you know
adds a whole nother to it I think
nuzlocks are also in that Goldilocks
yeah those looks great of like just it's
like it's challenging enough where you
need to do some prep work and you need
to think about like team structure but
it doesn't take so much time that it
takes the fun out of it right you know
and and you know it's like it's super
rewarding when you win it's super
punishing when you lose but it just
makes you want to keep coming back right
like you've been doing a lot of nuzlocks
recently yeah dude fun people like it
it's easy to understand yeah it's like
dark souls for kids
Dark Souls baby steps I like how a dark
souls and synonyms for just difficulty
yeah Dark Souls isn't a difficulty
actually uh difficulty in video games
didn't exist Before Dark Souls
definitely not that's also [__] yeah
sorry don't screw back to it again but
that's one thing I also really liked
about um that 300 game is that like uh
like everything because because all the
fights weren't necessary it was really
interesting because like you had a talk
option with whoever you were fighting
right it's always risky to do it because
what if you talk to them they'd [__]
clap you and then you're like [__] I
lost a turn uh but then like Sunday some
ways like the only way to get characters
to join a party was mid-fight to talk to
them and this is never explained or
anything like that and it's a pretty
interesting course because it was
basically like how I described it to
people and how people subscribe to me
was uh undertale meets berserk
which is why I like that because it was
like fighting is cool and it's
turn-based combat but fighting isn't the
only option there's a lot of other ways
we've got approaching yeah
you actually got to find something
you can't figure out in berserk that's
yeah let's see how well that goes it's
like an undertale but if everyone wasn't
reasonable because it's realistic right
because somebody's thinking monsters
they don't [__] want to talk to you
yeah is a [__] disembodied monster
with his dick out doesn't want to talk
oh he doesn't want to talk he wants to
kill you why don't you try and talk to
you idiot yeah and it punishes you for
that so I like that I like that if that
felt real uh I think I just need games
with Stakes I guess the problem is that
uh turn based combat like a lot of RPGs
or jpgs give you a lot of saves they're
like very very generous it saves a lot
of this yeah yeah and that almost kind
of takes away from my enjoyment because
I'm like I just don't feel like I have
any difficulties just too much of a game
of
um the complete opposite I need to be
spoon fed yes what the [__] like like I
do not want to work for anything no no I
I like the idea of nuzlocks but like
unless the game was designed that way
I'm like why would I bring artificial
difficulties so much better than the
base game it's it's way more fun because
it's actually like his Pokemon
especially like new Pokemon yeah it's
like Google gaga [__] like that yeah
yeah everyone we're also adults now yeah
I know I know but like like those games
that are made for life okay here's
here's what I can never do something
like a Nuzlocke okay when when you when
I'm playing
okay when okay I don't know if this is a
mental thing but like when I'm beating a
game that is designed to be difficult
it's it's like this is the way that it
is designed and I'm beating someone
else's work that is their work yeah when
I'm doing a Nuzlocke I am putting
difficulty upon myself so basically the
only the only challenge the the only
opponents I'm trying to beat here is
myself because I'm imposing all the
difficulty of myself and I'm like I
don't want to do that I wanna I
understand that yeah yeah I I I I I
don't want to challenge myself I want to
challenge someone else I want to
challenge someone else's design if that
makes sense no no that totally makes
sense and I'm normally in the same boat
with you yeah uh I think there are just
some exceptions where it feels like
there's a challenge that is just lacking
there and that artificially making one
does kind of solve a lot of the issues
perhaps the game might have for somebody
who I mean I you know I'm not a kid it's
the Pokemon was not designed for me yeah
oh suddenly you had this kind of factor
and it becomes a lot more oh this is way
more engaging suddenly because now I'm
not just gonna go willy-nilly into every
fight I'm gonna have to actually think
and we have to plan just like randomized
nuzlocks are very fun because you just
like imagine gotcha then you don't know
where anything is and you're just like
all right this this character just one
shot at me and I have I have
repercussions for that uh I think that's
the problem I have with a lot of games
is that they just often don't punish you
ever but then punishing is a difficult
thing to do right like how do you add
punishment to a game or Stakes to a game
that don't actually uh just take
advantage of your time as a player yeah
yeah like and so I understand why a lot
of games are like let's just let's just
make a good game let's not let's not do
that because also not everyone wants
that and I understand that and I'm not
imposing that on anyone I'm not being
like you have to play it this way like
there's a lot of games out there
especially like story driven games where
it's like this is not made so that you
struggle like this is great so you can
get to story beat to story beat maybe
there's a there's a hard boss here and
there but the most of it is pretty
doable yeah yeah and I understand that
um but that's why a lot of those games I
just don't I also don't go for because
that just doesn't appeal to me yeah it's
like an interactive movie well yeah like
there's a lot of games I've played
around like this is just uh the
cutscenes and then the gameplay is a
vehicle to the next Cuts yeah yeah uh I
haven't played like the last of us but I
imagine it's something similar it's the
gameplay is not that incredibly
difficult and it's more so about getting
from A to B yeah I mean that is 100 a
story right I mean I mean The Last of Us
is a HBO series in a video game that
they turned into a HBO series right like
that I would never be like you should do
a [__] no hit run of last year it's
like
why yeah it's like you're trying to
snort a milkshake it's like it should
not like it's not made for that at all I
was actually like it's it's so weird now
because uh I I did actually watch The
Last of Us it's gonna just [__]
incredible insane right absolutely
incredible but now like after I've
watched the HBO Last of Us I can never
go back to playing the game because to
me it's just so much better I right yeah
I I I've I never I never played the game
right but I watched the TV show and I
was like man they've
given such a good depth to these
characters I just can't yeah imagine how
it would work in the game anymore I'm
sure it does but in my head I'm like I
just don't know how Okay because as
someone who like I I was very
apprehensive about watching the like The
Last of Us HBO series because I'm just
like I've played the game I know the
story what else is there to do and I
kind of realize now the difference when
it comes to presenting a story in a
video game versus just watching a movie
or watching a TV series uh because the
story in The Last of Us HBO TV series
was just like perfectly paced yeah you
know it's it's just perfectly placed and
then now now what I want now when I go
back to playing the game I cannot just
think okay I'm getting the story in
little increments yeah right because I
need to I need to splice in the gameplay
between those little increments and you
know last of us is a very it's a [__]
great game but it's not got the greatest
gameplay in the world compared to other
you know other games in this genre of
what the thing that made it stand out
was the writing was so good and the
gameplay was good it enough to be like
okay this is good enough
um it's not gonna revolutionize the
industry with this gameplay but it's
good enough to uh get you through the
game and get you through the story and
now that the TV series exists I'm like
[__] now that a TV series exists I feel
like it's just completely made uh
like
it's completely made what The Last of Us
game made that so special just like mute
now because I'm just like if you want to
experience the story of The Last of Us I
feel like you should just watch the TV
series because that's that's a better
paced story that's told not it's not
told better but the the way it's told
the way is presented just because of the
nature of video games versus movies it's
just a better story you know my favorite
episode is like episode three holy [__]
which wasn't even in the TV yeah such a
good episode and such a good way of
showing like characterization and yeah
how this zombie apocalypse would affect
certain people and yeah so that's great
uh I need to get on it it's so it's so
good
um yeah that's my favorite episode but
like the one thing that I thought the
show did really well which obviously
this is a lot easier to convey and I
felt like when I was when I was watching
it I was like how would you how'd you
convey this in the game which was they
they make violence like violence against
other humans seem like a pretty
traumatic thing yeah for the young like
Ellie the younger character to
experience yeah which in the game I feel
like when it's like all right go you
control the character gun down 50 men it
just doesn't feel like it doesn't feel
impactful but like watching maybe an
actor do that and the ramifications of
that it definitely feels like oh your
violence is bad
like but in video games you don't feel
like violence is bad cause you do it all
the [__] time
maybe I haven't played the game so I
don't know but the one thing that's the
one thing I was like I wonder if this is
why
it was so divisive you know because
obviously I haven't I don't even know
what happened I don't even know what
happened second game but I know the big
plot twist because everyone [__] it
turns like a woke right versus left
thing yeah yeah yeah and I wonder if
that's almost why
like the the second game was received
kind of badly was because maybe the game
didn't characterize Joel in a way that
made it seem question I don't know it's
kind of spoilers but I don't know like
sport kind of questionable maybe killing
people all the time I don't know yeah I
mean I think the second game took a very
very big risk yeah and I actually
respect them for taking that risk uh
because I didn't know how they were
going to make a sequel to The Last of Us
um and uh they they took a risk with
their story nor it didn't gel with
everyone but that's that to me is the
sign of you know someone who wants to
like push you know push push the limit
and push the limit uh push the
storytelling uh I could see HBO doing it
right yeah I could just see him doing it
right they're like the kings of doing
controversial [__] and like okay look at
every goddamn Game of Thrones yeah yeah
yeah yeah like they took the last of us
which is already a great story and great
characters and I think they made it
better and that that is that is what I
would that was that is what I took out
from being apprehensive about watching
The Last of Us originally
um I and now I'm just like if you want
to experience loss of us I'd say just
watch the TV series because it's so
[__] good it's amazing yeah really
[__] good yeah super hyped for the
next season in like 10 years yeah
whatever if I can get there it's gonna
be so long yeah that was I guess our
Mini review of The Last of Us and uh all
the games all the other things
tie hentai please no never never again
never never again oh God keep the
animation studio there's a part of
there's a part of me that wants to go
watch it but you should you should just
for the experience
it looks way better than Queen B that's
what I'm that's all I'll say that's not
Quimby uh they're not that bad all right
next next week will be my full
comprehensive review of my mama I look
forward to that but uh hey look at all
these patrons though they're pretty
great they won't watch Tai hentai
hopefully please yeah don't yet but hey
if you like to support the show then
head on over to our patreon patreon.com
trash taste also follow us on Twitter
send us some memes on the subreddit and
if you hate our face listen to us on
Spotify and we will see you guys next
week all right see you guys bye
foreign
[Music]